io ho dodici anni fa era un fisico
teorico e come tale mi occupavo di
teorie
molto astratte e a volte anche un po
astruse e non avevo nessuna possibilità
di vedere dal vivo i fenomeni di cui mi
occupavo dal punti sia teorico
come potete immaginare come mi sentivo
quando tutte le sere tornando a casa dal
mio ufficio a roma
d'inverno vedeva uno spettacolo come
questa questi sono degli stormi di
storni sul cielo di roma
questo era un fenomeno innanzi tutto
bellissimo e poi che avveniva di davanti
a me davanti ai miei occhi e io facevo
cose molto molto più astratte
tendenzialmente un po inutili
non sapevo neanche il nome di questo
fenomeno quel tempo poi l'ho imparato
comportamento collettivo e decisi che
volevo occuparmene però avevo bisogno di
una scusa perché certamente questa non
era fisica teorica la scusa però ce
l'avevo perché io mi occupavo di materia
condensata quindi sistemi di molti atomi
o molecole che interagiscono in qualche
modo dando luogo a delle formazioni
complesse
qui sicuramente abbiamo delle particelle
sarebbero gli uccelli sicuramente
interagiscono in qualche modo e la
struttura a cui danno luogo e complessa
una sorta di nuovo tipo di materia di
materia attiva di materia biologica e
quindi ci si di studiarlo cercare dei
finanziamenti e avevo anche un altro
vantaggio il vantaggio era appunto che
ero un fisico teorico che visite ore ci
sono un po come i ninja della scienza
possono fare con meno pensano di poter
fare qualsiasi cosa dal studiare al
bosone di higgs a come si propagano le
onde di informazione né gli stormi di
uccelli e c'era anche un altro buon
motivo per studiare questo sistema ed è
che il comportamento collettivo avviene
in moltissimi sistemi diversi in
biologia e non solo in biologia e su
scale anche molto diverse ad esempio
questa è una colonia di cellule
staminali che cresce
all'inizio sembra molto random molto
casuale movimento invece poi col tempo
vedete che si installano dei moti
collettivi molto complessi e questo è
qualcosa che ancora non si capisce
ancora stiamo cercando di studiarlo
anche semplicemente prendere i dati non
è facile poi abbiamo comportamento
collettivo negli sciami di insetti
uno sciame di zanzare della malaria la
giunta della malaria si accoppiano
durante questi formazioni di sciami ed è
chiaramente molto importante dal punto
vista del controllo della malaria capire
come funziona questo meccanismo cioè
comportamento collettivo nei gruppi di
pesci naturalmente negli uccelli come vi
ho già mostrato quel puntino piccolino
il falco il falco pellegrino che sta
attaccando lo stormo cercano di
spezzarlo al centro
abbiamo anche lo stesso tipo di
comportamento nei mammiferi
queste sono pecore e anche in un animale
molto particolare che l'uomo cioè vari
esempi di comportamento collettivo
quello che noi dobbiamo tenere presente
quando affrontiamo questo problema dal
punto del fisico e che fisica biologia
hanno alcune fondamentali differenze
allora in fisica quello che noi siamo
abituati fare è di partire dal
microscopico e arrivare al macroscopico
ad esempio noi studiamo la forza di
attrazione fra due cariche elettriche e
da li cerchiamo di predire quale sarà la
maniera in cui si alzano i capelli di un
bambino quando va solo scivola in
biologia non possiamo fare questo perché
non possiamo mettere due uccelli sul
trespolo e misurare la forza tra questi
uccelli semplicemente non funziona
quindi in biologia dobbiamo procedere
all'opposto nella fisica in fisica
studiamo le interazioni microscopiche
cerchiamo di predire i fenomeni
macroscopici in biologia invece
misuriamo i fenomeni macroscopici e
procedendo al contrario cerchiamo di
capire quali sono le interazioni
microscopiche che danno luogo a quei
fenomeni si chiama problema inverso per
fare questo abbiamo bisogno di dati di
dati sperimentali e questo è quello che
abbiamo fatto per vari anni appollaiati
sul tetto di vari palazzi a roma
prendere immagini degli stormi in volo
da vari punti di vista questa si chiama
stereometria e non è proprio come bere
un bicchier d'acqua perché vedete che
c'è un problema molto grave che accada
volte cioè di uccelli come nella camera
destra possono sovrapporsi uno all'altro
e quindi voi perdete tracce
dell'identità tuttavia per fortuna noi
abbiamo varie
macchine fotografiche varie telecamere e
in quel modo noi possiamo ricostruire
loro vera identità e quindi possiamo
trasformare un video come questo in un
set di dati sperimentali ora abbiamo una
posizione la velocità di ogni singolo
individuo nel tempo e possiamo calcolare
quello che vogliamo e cosa vogliamo
calcolare beh la cosa che ci interessa
di più è l'interazione come
interagiscono questi individui allora
c'è una cosa comune a tutte le forze
della natura ed è che le forze della
natura decadono quella distanza con la
distanza metrica in metro in chilometri
fra gli oggetti vale per la gravità per
i pianeti ma vale anche all'altro
estremo delle scale di lunghezze vale
per le forze atomiche
allora la cosa interessante è che quando
noi ci siamo messi a fare questo lavoro
c'erano già molti modelli e teorie del
comportamento collettivo in biologia
formulate dai biologi
eppure l'assunzione era la stessa che in
fisica e cioè che la forza sociale fra
gli animali fra gli individui decadesse
all'aumentare della distanza quello che
abbiamo trovato è che la situazione è in
realtà molto diversa
un singolo individuo non interagisce con
tutti gli individui entro una certa
distanza come accadrebbe in fisica ma
interagisce con un numero fisso di
individui in particolare un numero
vicino a 7
questo vuol dire che in uno stormo molto
denso come quello in alto il raggio di
interazione molto piccolo in uno stormo
invece molto poco denso come quello in
basso al raggio è molto grande loro se
ne fregano della distanza dei vicini
la cosa importante che tengono sotto
controllo un numero fisso di vicini
questa e un'interazione molto diversa da
quella della fisica e possiamo
riformularle in questo modo è come se
gli uccelli usassero una nozione diversa
di distanza non misura le distanze in
metri ma il numero di uccelli fra loro è
un altro punto e questo è quello che
fate anche voi quando piate la
metropolitana e non misurate la distanza
in metro in chilometri ma il numero di
fermate e la distanza naturale in ogni
network anche sociale non è la distanza
vera fisica fra due persone quella che
conta mano
i gradi di separazione e questo è quello
che accade anche negli uccelli
però se ci pensate 7 vicini e pochissimo
7 vicini sono veramente soltanto effetti
uccelli intorno a voi
queste sono stormi di migliaia decine di
migliaia volte anche centinaia di
migliaia di individui come fanno a
coordinarsi in questa maniera fantastica
che avete visto all'inizio interagendo
soltanto con 7 vicini per volta il
trucco di questa di questo miracolo è
quello della correlazione cos'è la
correlazione la correlazione è una sorta
di trasferimento indiretto di
comunicazione pensate al gioco del
telefono che fanno i bambini ogni
bambino sussurra un messaggio soltanto
l'orecchio del primo vicino quindi
interagisce con una persona
eppure il messaggio può viaggiare molto
più lontano di una persona quindi la
freccia nera vi dice che il raggio e di
interazione di uno voi parate soltanto
col vostro diretto e vicino la freccia
rossa è il raggio di correlazione che
può essere anche molto più ampio quello
che noi possiamo fare adesso avendo i
dati degli uccelli e di far giocare
questo gioco del telefono allo stormo
quindi possiamo misurare veramente
quanto è larga questa correlazione è
quello che troviamo una cosa molto
sorprendente qui abbiamo su questo asse
la distanza in individui quindi la
distanza da un individuo fissato con un
altro individuo la curva rossa ed
interazione vi ho già detto decade molto
in fretta entro i primi 7 10 vicini e
già 0 la curva blu incredibilmente e la
correlazione dentro lo stormo volete che
la curva blu va 0 molto dopo la
colorazione molto molto ampia quello che
troviamo in realtà è che ampia quanto
l'intero gruppo
quindi nonostante la comunicazione si è
fatta veramente parlando direttamente
solo con pochi individui
il messaggio raggiunge tutto il gruppo
questa è stata una cosa un po
sorprendente per noi
all'inizio c'era venuto il dubbio a noi
ad altri che questo il segreto di questo
fenomeno fosse nel grande ordine nel
sistema
avete visto uno stormo di uccelli è un
sistema molto ordinato tutti volano più
o meno nella stessa direzione
e quindi uno potrebbe pensare che
l'ordine sia il vero segreto per
mantenere questa correlazione in realtà
non è affatto così
quello che abbiamo fatto per capirlo di
studiare un sistema molto disordinato
tra gli sciami di moscerini
questa è una ripresa che abbiamo fatto è
quella di destra è la ricostruzione
tridimensionale di questo step vero chan
e ora siete d'accordo che questo non è
assolutamente un sistema ordinato è
molto diverso da un nostro uomo di
uccelli sembra completamente
all'estremo opposto eppure quello che
abbiamo trovato
incredibilmente e che la correlazione la
maniera in cui l'informazione si propaga
in questo sistema è altrettanto efficace
che negli uccelli degli stormi di
uccelli
quindi sembra che l'ordine non sia la
chiave o perlomeno non nel modo in cui
noi pensavamo e quindi qual è il segreto
di questa coordinazione
ora qui siamo in un territorio in parte
ancora inesplorato dove il dibattito
scientifico è molto acceso per non dire
feroce come come giusto che sia quindi
quella che vi sto dando la mia il mio
personale convincimento temporaneo come
tutto in fisica nella scienza quello che
volete capire che tutti i sistemi fisici
possono essere diciamo catalogati in
base a quanto sono ordinati uno sciame è
disordinato uno stormo di uccelli e
ordinato un banco di pesci così così
quindi immaginate di catalogare i vostri
sistemi collettivi in base a quanto sono
ordinati ora quello che si può vedere
quello che si scopre quando si studiano
questi fenomeni è che la risposta
collettiva del sistema cioè quanto il
sistema e reagisce come un unico
organismo a uno stimolo esterno e
massima vicino al confine fra ordine e
disordine un sistema molto disordinato e
chiaramente non riesce a rispondere
collettivamente questo è ovvio
non si può rispondere collettivamente in
maniera buona se c'è un totale caos
ma la cosa interessante è che vale anche
il viceversa anche un sistema molto
troppo ordinato non è
buono per coordinare collettivamente un
cambio del sistema e questo è meno
intuitivo ma che vedere col fatto che
non siamo molto ordinato a una forte
inerzia sociale possiamo chiamarla
ognuno tende a continuare a fare quello
che il sistema sta già facendo
e quindi molto difficile propagare dei
cambi collettivi del sistema attraverso
il gruppo quindi moscerini uccelli
sciami e stormy vivono tutti e due
vicino a questo picco della risposta
collettiva anche se sui versanti diversi
del confine tra ordine e disordine
questo è forse il messaggio che più può
avere a che fare con il tema di questo
ted a me non è chiaro cosa possa
succedere nei sistemi sociali e
sicuramente siamo ancora molto lontani
da poter dare anche una minima
conclusione però la domanda se un
sistema sociale anche umano funziona
allo stesso modo cioè se la miglior
risposta collettiva possibile sia vicino
al confine tra ordine e disordine
a mio parere molto affascinante grazie